This video highlights new and existing view
options for Alignment tracks in the GDV, NCBI's
Genome Data Viewer.
We'll focus on BAM alignment data that are
hosted remotely, and how to view haplotype
structural variation, but many of the display
options you'll see also apply to viewing other
types of data, such as BLAST results and SRA
data.
I'll start on the GDV home page and for this
demo change to the GRCh37 assembly and click
Browse Genome.
To load the remote BAM file, use the User
Data and Track Hubs menu.
I'll first point out the Supported File and
Data types.
Notice that for remote BAM and VCF files,
the directory you point to must contain the
corresponding index files.
Okay, I'll select Options, add Remote Files,
and paste in the URL for my file, and I'll
give the new track a name, trio, and click
Add.
You see a warning, but the data were added
successfully.
Warnings like these report incongruities between
the file and the genome assembly, for instance
that the file contains extra sequences that
aren't in the assembly.
Details has more specific information.
Your added tracks are placed at the bottom,
but you can move any track by click and drag
in the tracks title bar.
I'm going to clean up a bit by using the red
X on the right to delete some tracks.
You might also notice that the added track
is shaded green.
This differentiates user added tracks from
those provided by NCBI.
At this zoom level we're seeing all of chromosome
1, and the coverage graph of reads in our
trio track appears to show good, even coverage
across the chromosome.
This big gap is the centromere region.
Let's zoom in a bit and display specific,
100 kilobase region by typing in the Search
widget on the left.
I want to go to chr1: 69,900K-70,000K.
We're getting more detail at this level, where
red denotes areas with more mismatches and
black denotes indel variation in the read
coverage.
In the region 69,940K to 69,945K, notice the
dips, suggesting deletions relative to the
genome reference.
I'll zoom to this region.
We see two regions where most of the reads
have these deletions or gaps.
I'll spend the next couple minutes adjusting
various track settings to explore some of
the display options available.
You can use the gear icon next to the delete
icon in the track title, or the one in the
tooltip.
I'll click on the one in the tooltip and change
a few settings.
I'll check the box to Show pileup, keeping
the Pileup Display set to Match/Mismatch graph
(count); in the Hide Alignments menu I'll
choose to hide both duplicates and bad reads;
in the Sort alignments by menu, I'll choose
Haplotype, then hit Apply.
The pileup graph is just below the track title,
and in this Match/Mismatch graph (count) display
clearly marks the two indel regions.
The reads are now clustered by haplotype;
haplotype 1, haplotype 2, and haplotype not
set.
Notice that haplotype 2 does not have the
deletions seen in haplotype 1.
Let's use highlight and zoom to sequence around
the smaller indel region on the left side.
At this level, all the mismatches, deletions
(the dark red lines) and insertions (the blue
bars) are apparent.
The length of an insertion correlates to size
of the blue bar.
Okay, let's look at one of the other pileup
display options.
I'll go back into track settings and change
Pileup Display to Match/mismatch table (count),
but you see that other options are available.
I'll hit Apply.
The pileup table now indicates the individual
read counts for a match, mismatch, gap, or
intron; refer to the legend on the left.
In addition, higher counts are shaded more
darkly.
You see this easily in the gap region.
Now let's take a look at a read's tooltip,
there is a lot of good information there.
A mouseover on a read's row activates the
tooltip, and I'll click on this pushpin to
keep it open.
So here we can get,
orientation
the span of that read on the reference molecule,
chr 1 in our case
% coverage, and so on
You also get a CIGAR string
And at the bottom you have a button called,
View, to see any unaligned regions.
Here the unaligned reads are in red, and you
can copy/paste this sequence for further analysis,
e.g., to see if this is vector sequence, or
part of a translocation or chimera?
Be aware that this tooltip information is
also present for other types of alignment
data, such as BAM files for expression data
or for BLAST data.
The last example is a quick look for NCBI
RefSNPs in the region of structural variation
we've seen here.
I want to add a track of those RefSNPs, so
I'll go to the Tracks menu, Configure Tracks,
and show the Variation tracks we can choose
from.
Let's go to the most recent dbSNP build, 153,
and select Live RefSNPs.
I'll hit Configure.
Here is the added RefSNPs track, and there
is a RefSNP in this region, the rs ending
in 8066.
In the tooltip for the rs, you get a link
to the SNP record where you can investigate
this further.
That's all for this video.
We'd love to have your questions and feedback,
so please use either the Feedback form in
the Help menu, or the Support Center link
near the bottom of most NCBI web pages.